GENERAL MATTIS.
JOINING ME NOW WITH REACTION IS
A FORMER DHS SPECIAL ADVISER
UNDER THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
AND BEN FREEMAN, SENIOR FELLOW
AND DEFENSE PRIORITIES.
GREAT TO HAVE BOTH OF YOU HERE
TONIGHT.
DAVID, YOU'RE OLD BOSS BARACK
OBAMA LARGELY WON THE PRESIDENC
ON HIS DON INTERVENTIONIST
MESSAGE SO, WHY DO YOU TAKE
ISSUE THAN WITH WHAT TRUMP HAS
DONE HERE IN SYRIA?
>> JUST LIKE PRESIDENT OBAMA
WASN'T EXACTLY PERFECT IN THE
WITHDRAWAL FROM IRAQ AND
AFGHANISTAN, I THINK THIS IS A
MISTAKE.
I AGREE WITH SOME OF WHAT YOU
SAID I DISAGREE WITH SOME OF
WHAT YOU SAID AS WELL.
I THINK IT WAS A MISTAKE BECAUS
IT'S BEYOND CONTRARY AND WE'VE
ALREADY DEFEATED ISIS.
THE MAJORITY OF THE NATIONAL
SECURITY ADMINISTRATION DON'T
THINK WE IT IS A GOOD IDEA TO
WITHDRAW 2,000 TROOPS FROM SYRIA
.
IT OPENS UP THE POTENTIAL FOR A
REFLASH.
THIS IS A LITTLE BIT LIKE
DECLARING VICTORY LANDING ON TH
AIRCRAFT CARRIER.
>> FOREIGN-POLICY MAGAZINE.
YOU LOOK A COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO
A COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO I WAS
READING ALL THE HEADLINES THIS
MORNING ON THE WAY DOWN HERE.
AND IT WAS FOREIGN-POLICY
SUCCESSES THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
MISSION ACCOMPLISHED AGAINST
ISIS.
OBVIOUSLY ISIS WANTS TO
RECONSTITUTE ITSELF FOR YOU
NEVER GOING TO DESTROY ALL OF
ISIS BUT IN THE AREA WE ARE
FOCUSED ON ISIS HAS BEEN DRIVEN
OUT.
I LOVE THIS DEED FROM EARLIER
TODAY.
HE SAID THE FOLLOWING.
I WILL PUT IT UP ON THE SCREEN.
HE BASICALLY SAID ANYONE WHO
CRITICIZED OBAMA AND
IRRESPONSIBLE WITHDRAW FROM
NEEDS TO CHECK THEIR HYPOCRISY.
YOU'RE REACTION THERE?
>> I THINK YOU'RE OVERSTATING
OBAMA HAS INTERVENTION.
HE WAS THE AUTHOR OF THE SURGE
IN AFGHANISTAN.
HE PUT FROM FORCES IN SYRIA.
I AGREE WITH YOU ON THIS WE NEE
A DEFINITION OF SUCCESS WERE
ISIS THE NATIONAL SECURITY
EXPERTS THAT WERE HEARING SO
MUCH FROM COMPLAINING ABOUT THI
HAVE A STANDARD DEFEAT FOR ISIS
THAT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO ACHIEVE.
SORT OF LIKE IF ANYBODY IN SYRI
THINKS NICELY AT ISIS OR SAYS
ANYTHING IN THEIR FAVOR, WE HAD
TO STAY IN SYRIA FOREVER.
I SHOULD DOESN'T HAVE ANY
TERRITORY ANYMORE.
IT'S AN IMPORTANT THING.
DRINKS ARE DECIMATED.
THEY BEEN MOSTLY KILLED.
IF THAT'S NOT SUCCESS, NOTHING
IS.
>> I WANT TO PLAY FOR YOU, SO
OUR VIEWERS REMEMBER, WHAT
DONALD TRUMP SAID HE WAS GOING
TO DO.
HIS GENERAL APPROACH, HE GAVE
HIS BIG FOREIGN-POLICY SPEED
SPEECH.
>> ENGAGED IN NATIONBUILDING
ABROAD.
THEY FILLED THE REPLENISH OUR
NATION AT HOME.
THEY UNDERCUT AND SHORTCHANGED
OUR MEN AND WOMEN IN UNIFORM
UNSTABLE FUNDING AND UNCLEAR
MISSIONS.
TAKE DAVID, THAT IS WHAT THE
PRESIDENT BASICALLY CAMPAIGNED
ON.
BARACK OBAMA SAID SOMETHING
SIMILAR,  BUT I THINK IS RIGHT,
REALISM ON THE GROUND IN
AFGHANISTAN A MINI SURGE IN
AFGHANISTAN, RELUCTANTLY
DEPLOYED TROOPS IN SYRIA.
HE DIDN'T WANT TO DO IT AT ALL
TRUMP SMASHED HIM BACK ON THE
RED LINE, BUT LISTEN, DONALD
TRUMP DIDN'T RESPOND TO THESE
CHEMICAL ATTACKS HE GOT
CRITICISM FROM A LOT OF FOLKS
WHEN HE DID THAT NON-
INTERVENTIONIST,  BUT HE DID
RESPOND.
IT'S NOT LIKE DONALD TRUMP HAS
DONE NOTHING IN SYRIA.
HERE ARE ALL THE DEMOCRAT THING
IS THAT A HERKY-JERKY
FOREIGN-POLICY I THINK IT'S BEE
FAIRLY CONSISTENT.
WE SAID WE GET IT DONE WERE
GOING TO BEGIN TO DRAW DOWN
TROOPS BECAUSE WE HAVE A LOT OF
STUFF TO DO ON THE HOMEFRONT.
THAT HAS FRANKLY NOT BEEN DONE
OR PAID FOR.
AND WE HAVE TO TAKE CARE OF
BUSINESS AT HOME.
>> WHAT GETS PEOPLE WORD IS THE
LACK OF NATIONAL SECURITY
DECISION-MAKING.
THERE IS NO STRATEGY
COMMUNICATION BIRD IS BIGGER
THAN SYRIA.
WHAT COULD THIS INCUBATE, WHAT
ARE THE RAMIFICATIONS FOR ISRAEL
?
THREE TRILLION DOLLARS SPENDING
ON IRAQ AND AFGHANISTAN IS HARD
TO DEFEND FOR ANY PERSPECTIVE
FROM ANY PARTY SO I THINK THE
ISSUE IS WHAT DO THESE 2,000
TROOPS REPRESENTED INTO THE
POTENTIAL OF A REFLASH AND GEBEN
, THERE IS ALWAYS A
POTENTIAL FOR REFLASH.
THAT'S WHY GOING INTO THESE VER
DIFFICULT TO MODULUS PLACES WIT
FACTIONS, ISIS IS PSEUDO- TERRO
GROUP.
NOW THE CHRISTIAN COMMUNITY THA
WAS PROTECTED BY A SOLID AND HA
BEEN DESTROYED AND BRUTALIZED
AND PERSECUTED UNDER ISIS AND
WHAT'S HAPPENED.
IT IS A COMPLEX WEB OF
RELATIONSHIPS AND DETAILS.
THE IDEA THAT THERE IS A GREAT
CONSTITUENCY FOR A RETURN TO
BUSH STYLE INTERVENTIONISM WHER
WE ESTABLISH THESE BEACHHEADS
AND NEVER LEAVE.
I THINK AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
FOREVER AT SOME POINTS IS GOING
TO AFFECT US REALLY BADLY BURNE
IT AT SOMEBODY IN THE WHITE
HOUSE IT DOES WANT TO DO ANY
FOREIGN-POLICY AT ALL.
>> IT'S ABOUT WAY TO CONSENSUS.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE NOT FOR
OCCUPATIONAL WARS.
IT CONTINUES JUST ON ME MEET TH
PEOPLE LOOKED INTO THAT WHAT
WELL.
I THINK WE SHOULD HAVE ANOTHER
OCCUPATIONAL WORK USING YOURS
MILITARY FOR AN END AND
CONTINUES TO BLOW ME AWAY THAT
THAT IS THE DEFAULT
FOREIGN-POLICY THINKING AROUND
HERE.
>> THERE HAS BEEN SOME CHANGES
IN THINKING.
I DON'T MIND WHEN PEOPLE EVOLVE
IN THEIR THINKING.
I WAS VERY WRONG WRONG WRONG
ABOUT THE WAR IN IRAQ, BUT AFTE
A WHILE IT BECAME OBVIOUS TO ME
TOO THAT IT WAS A HUGE MISTAKE.
THE IT'S KIND OF CONFUSING WHIC
HE'S COME DOWN ON THIS ISSUE.
LET'S HEAR WHAT YOU SAID LAST
NIGHT.
WATCH.
>> THE WAY THAT U.S. TROOPS ARE
FADING ISIS IN SYRIA IS IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE KURDISH
FIGHTERS WHO ARE BELIEVED BY TH
U.S. MILITARY TO BE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE ANTI- ISIS FORCE ON
THE GROUND.
IF THE U.S. IS GOING TO LEAVE I
DEVASTATION FOR THE KURDS.
>> EVEN IN AN INTERVIEW SHE DID
FOR A BOOK EARLIER, AN EXCERPT
FROM THIS BOOK CALLED DIRECT,
SHE SAID IN PART WE DON'T NEED
RADICAL.
WE JUST NEED A SMALL SEED
CONSERVATIVE RETURN TO OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL ROOTS OF COURSE
CORRECTION ADVOCATING AGAINST
THE ALMOST COLONIAL APPROACH TO
FOREIGN POLICY.
I THINK THE LEFT IS REALLY KIND
OF CAUGHT IN BETWEEN TWO
DIFFERENT POSITIONS HERE AND I
THINK IT IS HARD TO SQUARE THE
CIRCLE.
>> I THINK THAT FOREIGN-POLICY
NEEDS TO BE DRIVEN FROM THE
CENTER.
WE MIGHT EVEN AGREE ON THAT.
YOU TALK ABOUT ALLIANCES AND IT
DOESN'T MEAN WERE AGAINST ALL
ALLIANCES.
WEEKEND TAKE OUR ALLIES AND MAK
THEM ADVERSARIES.
I'M NOT SURE IT'S A GOOD IDEA T
MAKE OUR AUTOCRATS AND MAKE THE
ALLIES.
THAT IS THE CHALLENGE THAT WE
HAVE TODAY.
I THINK THIS IS TOO MUCH OF A
DANGEROUS WORLD.
>> OKAY, BUT WE'RE DEALING WITH
CHINA.
CHINA WE DO WITH CHINA.
THEY HAVE A MARXIST-LENINIST
REGIMES.
WE DEAL WITH BAD ACTORS MORNING
NOON, AND NIGHT, TIMEOUT.
UNIVERSITIES.
HOLLYWOOD.
WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH IT REAL
QUICK.
ANY PICS?
>> I CAN'T THINK OF ANYONE WHO
WOULD TAKE THE JOB THAT I COULD
RECOMMEND FOR IT.
>> DAVID, ANYONE?
>> BILL COHEN, HE'S NOT GOING T
TAKE THE JOB EITHER.
TAKE MINE IS JIM WEBB.
>> I WOULD LIKE THAT.